it's Friday that means we're gonna close
this special the only way we know how
with a Dan bond G no news explosion
joins us good to see you Dan good to see
you too Tucker
listen I'm really excited about this one
today I've got three new Z's for you
so let's start with an explosive story
number tween listen I watched and
listened to your de Blasio interview
last night very well done and listen I
give the guy credit he came on the show
all right but the guys hovering about 2%
above the Grim Reaper in approval polls
and I gotta tell ya make him talk can
this dude duck a question or what I mean
it was like he was like Tyson coming in
from he cannot I think we actually have
some video of this ducking just about
every question yes check this out
the city is dirty and it's getting
dirtier one of my producers told me just
yesterday that he was in a crowded
subway car and a man dropped his
trousers and defecated in the middle of
the car and no one did anything about it
you endorsed decriminalizing public
urination no absolutely that's
absolutely false
listen any offense like that gets a
summons there's a penalty there's
definitely a sanction we don't believe
in that you weaken the sanction against
public urination this smells like urine
do you notice that true I go all over
New York City all the time I'm sorry
I've been here for decades and decades
this city is more orderly and cleaner
and safer than has been for many many
years
manure sparked Tucker about this whole
thing is when he did answer the question
he made it up you were absolutely right
they changed the lineup urination thing
from a criminal summons to a civil court
so he couldn't even think it because
it's a civil rights issue public
urination no I know where whatever yes
Artie this guy even live in New York
anymore
I mean my gosh what is he missing I got
two more of these together explosive
story
but the Biden Chronicles continue listen
the reason I call him the Biden
Chronicles is his stories are great I
mean they really are and Biden lousy
stories on the campaign trail Tucker
they're they're touching their heart
breaking the the problem is Tucker
none of them actually happened there
they're not real stories I mean listen I
get it I heard you say this and there's
a part of me that really feels bad I
think Barack Obama gave them good advice
Joe you really don't need this but the
Chronicles they're really wonderful
stories the problem Joe is they just
didn't happen so I you know nice work
and all but you maybe it's time to kind
of think this thing through you know I'm
not working out baby
all right you go ahead I just my heart
is broken when I think about I just feel
sad about turbine blast every time I
look at him I think you could have just
retired you could be in Barbados right
now with your grandkids what are you
doing I know I heard you say that last
night throw that show I was listening I
and you're right it is it's tough to
watch I mean my Secret Service friends
would work for him like the guy and this
is just not ending well so poor Joe but
Story number one is my favorite they
hypocritical Democrats during that CNN
seven-hour commercial for the Republican
Party you're that climate change thing
whatever that was they want to ban
everything Tucker these are the worst
got a hypocrite if I have a list for you
okay here's what they want to ban vote
you vote for the Democrats in 2020 they
want to ban coal natural gas air travel
the combustion engine fracking offshore
drilling meat cheeseburgers I'm not
going anywhere without my food burger
and even worse they want to ban plastic
straws for those cardboard ones I got a
little kombucha here that is never gonna
leave my straw from here
dan bungee no one more cold dead hands
the right damn bungee no exploding the
news have the best weekend Dan